toutes les deux minutes un avion fait
son approche d'atterrissage au dessus de
la ville de mexico
environ 600 atterrissage par jour donc à
l'aéroport international benito juarez
un des plus conventionnels du monde
[Musique]
le trafic est tel que par manque de
porte d'embarquement
un grand nombre de vols décollent en
retard du matin un seul aéroport pour
une métropole géante de 25 millions
d'habitants cela fait près de vingt ans
que les gouvernements mexicains se
succèdent et échoue à trouver une
solution à l'engorgement conspiration
dès le passage la forme le symbôle aux
nationalistes finalement en 2015 les
travaux de ce qui devait être un des
plus grands aéroports du monde commence
à quelques kilomètres de l'aéroport
actuel et l'architecte norman foster et
fernando romero voulait en faire aussi
le plus beau du monde et le plus
écologique
livraison prévue 2020 mais même si au
moins 30 % des travaux sont complétés le
président élu
andres manuel lopez obrador amelot comme
on l'appelle arrête définitivement les
travaux entamés par son prédécesseur
enrique peña nieto on annule tout et on
fera autre chose et ses vannes à
construire d'hospice tass et n'allez
pourtant mais il est tard et santa luzia
sans talent aussi à mexico et toluca
trois aéroports au lieu d'un une folie
effectivement c'est une folie mais il ya
des raisons pour cette fois gaston mélo
est un observateur très branché sur le
monde des affaires mexicain un seul mot
résume la décision d'am l'eau corruption
c'était des concessions donner aux amis
aux emplois à l'entourage au cercle
rouge du pouvoir pour vivre ans à tout
court qui n'était pas pour le précédent
la république
quelque chose d'acceptable pays ferment
ya de la drogue clairement il ya de la
corruption la dent donc on va pas faire
on va pas faire cet aéroport
voici l'aéroport en construction fin
la gigantesque chantier est déjà bien
avancé brutalement lorsque le nouveau
président prend le pouvoir en janvier
2019 tout s'arrête
[Musique]
le chantier restent déserts 700 contrats
ont été annulés
les constructeurs ont reçu des
compensations ça coûte cher mais les
économies dit le président se feront
avec la construction du troisième
aéroport à la base militaire de santa
lucia
vends mon char à mazet 6000 militaires
voici la base actuelle c'est la base
aérienne numéro 1 la plus importante du
mexique
elle sert en particulier à organiser et
répartir les secours en cas de
catastrophe naturelle dans le pays et
ailleurs
voici maintenant la vision de lopez
obrador il veut faire vite
il dit que ce sont les militaires qui le
construit rond il coûte moins cher ils
peuvent travailler jour et nuit
[Musique]
deuxièmement l'aéroport actuel de mexico
sera agrandie d'un ou deux terminaux de
plus et enfin lopez obrador veut
ressusciter la vocation internationale
du petit aéroport de toluca de l'autre
côté de la capitale
[Musique]
petit détail toluca se trouve à 69 km en
voiture de l'aéroport actuel mais à 125
de celui de santa lucia cauchemar en
perspective
où est la logique mais écoutez la
logique de ce pays voyons nous ouvre la
capitale du surréalisme était bien dit
c'était bien étudié ces sont des
décisions des solutions tarabiscoté
s'est payé très tarabiscoté il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas une idée du pays des
citoyens de san salvador atenco se sont
battu férocement pendant 20 ans contre
le projet d'aéroport est mort des
détenus des femmes violées dit galicia
qui avait 60 ans quand la lutte a
commencé
elle est contente le maire est d'accord
nous avons conservé nos richesses
naturelles notre identité la
tranquillité
ça n'a pas de prix tout le monde n'est
pas de cet avis en particulier dans la
localité voisine de 5000 yens tokyo il a
qui du jour au lendemain a perdu la plus
grande partie de son activité économique
85% de la communauté avait du travail en
relation avec le nouvel aéroport en
construction commerce transports
immobilier
[Musique]
le projet est immobilisé mail est il
pour autant pour toujours les accès
autoroutiers sont construits les entrées
sont prêtes
même si on a effacé son nom anaïs et m
il y encore de l'activité à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte le bras de fer continue
entre ceux qui veulent conserver les
constructions actuelles et le président
qui veut tout inondé et redonner si
possible sa vie à l'ancien lac de
texcoco ce qui reste du grand lac
préhispanique de d'hénoch dinklage
certains comme le maire de tokoin là
sont prêts à parier que dans cinq ans
parce que lopez obrador ne pourra pas se
représenter
le projet d'aéroport renaîtra la rentrée
mais la patience latitude procédurale
quelle question de patience et d'
attitude positive dit le maire